rejoint maintenant michel doré qui est
propriétaire de quatre hôtels dans le
vieux-québec ancienne présidente de
l'association des hôteliers de québec
bonjour madame de riz madame de risques
vous m'entendez bien je vous attends oui
je vous souhaite une bonne nouvelle
alors parlons un peu de donc de la
situation si les américains ouvrent
leurs frontières aux touristes après le
21 juin et pas nous quel sera l'effet
selon vous sur vos hôtels sur
l'industrie touristique que ce soit
l'industrie touristique du vieux québec
ou du vieux montréal
ça va être une catastrophe parce que la
majorité des centres ville vit du
tourisme étranger souvent ce ne sont pas
les québécois qui viennent
ni centre ville de québec mais
centre-ville de montréal
alors qu'est ce qu'on va voir comme
saison touristique malgré certaines
promotions faites en collaboration avec
le ministère du tourisme la ville
on ne peut pas se permettre on ne peut
pas se permettre d'avoir un deuxième été
comme on a eu les dépenses on peut pas
se permettre de ne pas avoir 50 % de
taux d'occupation
il faut qu'on oublie c'est la survie de
plusieurs hôtels dans le vieux-québec et
d'un vieux montréal en ce moment c'est
la survie des autres ok qu'est ce que
vous espérez donc du gouvernement
fédéral à partir de là bas qui réouvre
les frontières écouté que se fasse comme
soit en ce moment l'union européenne se
prépare à avoir ce qu'ils appellent leur
pass vaccinale ou ceux qui sont vaccinés
qui ont l'oeil de doses peuvent rentrer
sans problème qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pour s'arrimer à ces mesures l'eau parce
que les touristes a mérité six viennent
pas au canada devront aller en europe et
on peut te quarantaine à faire en europe
à partir du moment où les tories sont
leurs deux doses
ils peuvent voyager non pas de mesures
sanitaires et non pas de mesures
restrictives contraire qu'il va rien je
comprends qu'il ya des choses mais en ce
moment il faut vraiment faire
la part entre l'économie et les mesures
sanitaires
on ne le vaccin est en ce moment aux
états unis les gens lui plus actionner
ce sont les gens du nord est des états
unis
ceux qui sont à clientèle primaire et à
québec et à montréal on en a besoin ils
sont nombreux qui ont deux sur lui ils
sont nombreux à chaque année en temps
normal ils sont nombreux du nord-est
américain à venir chez vous puis à venir
au québec c'est 50 pose la majorité de
nos clients dans les hôtels du
centre-ville de montréal et de québec
monsieur fillion 700 m
c'est la grosse majorité de nos clients
est ce que les touristes québécois qui
ne sortent pas qu'ils sont pas sortir
l'été passé puis qui pourront peut-être
pas sortir cet été pour aller ailleurs
est-ce que c'est suffisant ça ce tour et
cela pour compenser les pertes qui sont
engendrés par la fermeture de frontières
n'ont absolument pas absolument pas plus
j'ai fait un exercice
hier hier j'ai essayé pour juste comme
pour moi pour mon initiation pour mon
idée de faire une réservation aux îles
de la madeleine
ok le 13 le 13 ou j'ai fait le même
exercice en esprit et j'ai fait le même
exercice en des saisies avec la majorité
aux et de l'ama vergne avec j'ai trouvé
une seule chambre disponible
ok j'ai vraiment bien travaillé en
esprit quelques chambres en gaspésie
dépendant des places 000 hockey dans les
hôtels en ce moment dans le vieux québec
je n'ai que 8% de quelqu'un de réservé
dans le lannic d'occuper la maison parce
que vous dites c'est que c'est une
catastrophe pour québec pour montréal
pour les grands ensembles mais pas
nécessairement pour les îles de la
madeleine où la gaspésie où il va y
avoir beaucoup de monde que ce soit les
laurentides des stries charlevoix
c'est complètement un autre un autre
enjeu ce sont vraiment les
centres-villes à ce moment ci ok qui
sont en difficulté parce que ce n'est
pas vous
- était être devant laquelle devant club
après tout les tracks hop on a vu c'est
peut-être qu'on souhaite le plus mais
malheureusement on n'a pas cet être-là
ils font dans leur faire d'autres choses
votre réservation
votre niveau de réservations madame doré
cet été de votre carnet de réservation
ça ressemble à quoi
dans ce format à ce moment je suis pas
plus qu'à 10% 8%
c'est sûr que les québécois ont réservé
à la dernière minute ça mais si on
regarde ce qui se passe ailleurs
comme je vous dis pour mont pour moins
mon idée j'ai fait cet exercice le hier
sans savoir quand je prendrai
aujourd'hui alors en perdition qu'on est
un guide sur une ouverture des
frontières c'est ça n'a pas d'alluré
l'on peut pas rester comme ça donc ça
vous prend un plein de réouverture et
une réouverture c'est ça vous demander
avec les personnes qui ont deux doses
qui pourrait à ce moment là voyager dit
vous madame doré on verra la suite des
choses de toute façon parce que la
dépression sont là ils viennent de toute
part merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci à plutôt à à bientôt et merci au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit